Schrödingers Katze ist Tod UND lebendig!
In dem Gedankenexperiment hatte der Wissenschaftler
Erwin Schrödinger die paradoxen Eigenschaften
der Quantenphysik formuliert.
Denn Schrödinger Katze stirbt durch den radioaktiven
Zerfall eines Atoms und da Atome laut der
Quantenphysik erst durch die Beobachtung einen
Zustand annehmen ist diese Katze in einer
verschlossenen Box zusammen mit dem Atom beides:
Tod und lebendig.
Und dieses Experiment wurde jetzt real mit
einem Laserstrahl umgesetzt.
Ich sage nur Achtung Brainfaq... bei Clixoom
Science & Fiction, hier gibt es täglich spannende
Wissenschaftsvideos.
Abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts. herzlich willkommen!
In Zukunft sollen Quantencomputer verbunden
werden und es uns ermöglichen, Botschaften
abhörsicher über große Distanzen zu verschicken.
Bedeutend dafür könnten sogenannte Katzen-Zustände
sein.
Und das lässt sich erklären mit dem Gedankenexperiment
von Erwin Schrödinger zur Quantenphysik aus
dem Jahr 1935, in der die Katze gleichzeitig
tot UND lebendig ist.
Eine Katze ist gemeinsam mit einer kleinen
Menge an radioaktiver Substanz in einer Kiste
eingesperrt.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass eines der radioaktiven
Atome in der nächsten Stunde zerfällt oder
nicht, ist gleich groß.
Ein Detektor ist über der Kiste installiert
und registriert, ob ein Atom seinen Zustand
ändert.
Falls radioaktives Material zerfällt, sorgt
ein Geigerzähler dafür, dass ein Hammer
einen Behälter mit Gift zerstört.
Das würde dann den Tod des Tieres bedeuten.
So weit so klar.
Doch Schrödinger stellte auch fest, dass
von Außen betrachtet ja gar nicht klar ist,
ob ein Atom zerfallen ist oder nicht - zumindest
solange die Kiste verschlossen ist.
Bis jemand die Box öffnet und nachschaut,
verharrt der Atomkern also in der Überlagerung
der beiden Zustände “zerfallen” und “ nicht
zerfallen”: Dabei hängt das Leben der Katze
doch gerade von diesem Zerfall des Atoms ab!
In seinem Gedankenexperiment befindet sich
die Katze also in einer Art Zwischenzustand,
in dem sie gleichzeitig tot und lebendig ist.
Bam!
Die Quantenmechanik sagt, dass der Zustand
erst dann eindeutig festgelegt ist, wenn die
Umwelt mit dem System interagiert.
Wenn also gemessen wird.
Dazu der Physiker Gerhard Rempe - er ist Direktor
am Max-Planck-Institut für Quantenoptik:
“Nach Erwin Schrödingers Idee kann ein
mikroskopisches Teilchen, wie zum Beispiel
ein Atom, sich gleichzeitig in zwei unterschiedlichen
Zuständen befinden.
Man spricht dann von Überlagerung.
Wenn es zudem mit einem makroskopischen Objekt
verschränkt wird, kann es seine Überlagerung
auch an dieses weitergeben.
Daraus ergibt sich das Beispiel von einer
Katze, die in Abhängigkeit vom Zerfall eines
radioaktiven Atoms zugleich lebendig und tot
sein kann – eine Vorstellung, die jeglicher
Alltagserfahrung widerspricht”.
Doch im im Mikrokosmos ist eine solche Überlagerung
von Zuständen gar nicht so ungewöhnlich.
Dazu ein Beispiel: Ein Atom kann sich gleichzeitig
nach links und nach rechts drehen.
Erst, wenn dazu eine Messung durchgeführt
wird, entscheidet sich, welche der Möglichkeiten
Realität wird.
Ähnlich beim Doppelspaltexperiment: Hier
kann ein Photon beispielsweise sowohl den
einen als auch den anderen Spalt durchdringen.
Erst durch die Messung selbst, wird der Weg
des Photons festgelegt!
Total verrückt.
Das Ziel von Forschungsteams weltweit ist
es, das philosophische Gedankenexperiment
von Schrödinger im Labor zu realisieren und
dabei diese quantenmechanisch überlagerten
“Katzenzustände” herzustellen und nachzuweisen.
Dafür gibt es verschiedene Modelle.
Allerdings ohne Katzen, denn es geht ja vielmehr
um die Überlagerungszustände von Quantenobjekten.
Die Kiste, in der die Katze eingesperrt ist,
besteht bei dem Experiment des Münchener
Forschungsteams aus einem Hohlraum mit zwei
gewölbten Spiegeln, einem sogenannten “optischen
Resonator”.
Darin ließen die Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftler ein Rubidium-Atom schweben.
Seine Quantenzustände bringen die Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftler in einen Überlagerungszustand.
Das Forschungsteam aus München nutzte ein
Modell, bei dem die Katze durch die Photonen
eines Laserpuls dargestellt wird.
Dieser wird durch die Wechselwirkung mit dem
Resonator mit dem Atom verschränkt.
Somit übernimmt das Laserlicht die Überlagerungseigenschaften
des Atoms, w Dazu Stephan Welte, einer der
beteiligten Forscher: “Es ist uns gelungen,
fliegende optische Katzenzustände herzustellen
und zu zeigen, dass sie den Vorhersagen der
Quantenmechanik entsprechen.
Wir konnten somit beweisen, dass unsere Methode
funktioniert und weiterhin untersuchen, welche
Parameter entscheidend sind.”
Und nicht nur das- Denn das Besondere bei
diesem Experiment ist zum einen, dass sich
die Art der Zustände gezielt steuern lässt.
Heißt also konkret, dass beliebig viele Zustände
mit unterschiedlichen Phasen der Überlagerung
hergestellt werden können.
Zudem kann die “Katze” den Kasten verlassen
und bleibt trotzdem im Überlagerungszustand.
Die Photonen behalten nämlich ihren Überlagerungszustand
-selbst, wenn sie durch eine Glasfaser gesendet
werden.
Die optischen Katzenzustände können somit
über weite Distanzen aufrecht erhalten bleiben.
Weil die “Katzen” in diesem System also
mobil sind, quasi fliegen gelernt haben, ist
das Forschungsteam mehr als optimistisch,
dass ihr Experiment bei der Entwicklung und
beim Betrieb futuristischer Quanten-Netzwerke
nützlich sein wird.
Denn diese “fliegenden optischen Katzen”
könnten in Zukunft verwendet werden, um Quanteninformationen
zu kodieren und zu übertragen.
Dazu Gerhard Rempe: “Schrödingers Katze
war ursprünglich in eine Kiste eingesperrt,
um Wechselwirkungen mit der Umgebung auszuschließen.
Optische Katzenzustände, wie wir sie realisiert
haben, sind nicht in eine Kiste eingesperrt,
sondern fliegen frei.
(...) In Zukunft möchten wir mit dieser Technologie
ganze Quantennetzwerke aufbauen, bei der fliegende
optische Katzen Information übertragen.”
Bleiben wir bei Katzen.
Tierversuche werden nämlich demnächst überflüssig:
Die Videopremiere auf unserem englischen Kanal:
“The end of animal testing” Auf jeden
Fall extrem interessant.
Hier draufklicken und ansonsten: Bis dann,
bleibt dran!